( intro music )
( audience applause )
Buenas tardes a los que
hablan español, mucho gusto.
Good afternoon, it's a pleasure
to be here with you all.
People say that our community
needs more scientists,
more writers,
entrepreneurs,
and social leaders.
But that's why society
should focus on childhood.
Allowing them to be
entrepreneurs from childhood.
Let's imagine
that you are a child
who wants to be
a baseball player.
What should you do?
( audience )
Practice?
Of course, practice, and
go to the baseball school.
If you want to be
a pianist or a violinist,
you should go to
the music school.
If you as a child,
want to be a singer,
there are places
where you can be trained.
But if you want to be
an environmentalist
where can you receive training?
There are no place.
There were no places to go.
In 1995 I was 10 when I decided
to start doing something
to help Grandmother Earth.
I invited my friends
to meet after school
and I told them about
environmental issues.
We wanted to protect
animals, plants and humans.
And dreamed about
spreading our movement
around the world.
Our name was HUNAB,
and it stands for
Humans Unite with
Nature in Harmony for
Beauty, Welfare,
and Willingness.
We discovered that the
worst environmental problem
that our society has to face
is not pollution,
nor extinction,
nor illegal trade,
neither global warming.
The worst environmental problem
is the lack of education
because this is the root
for all those problems.
But we, as a group, we have
faced our own challenge,
the lack of credibility
because of our age.
Fortunately and after 19
years, we survived it.
( laughter )
And now we are
focused on education
as our main element
to solve and to eradicate
environmental problems.
Education is
a continuous process
where a person acquires
knowledge, awareness,
and the skills
to make decisions.
Education requires
continuous time and efforts.
And in fact, I am
still astonished about why,
in my country,
and in the world,
environmental education
is not included
as a main subject in
the school's curriculum,
when Mexico is
one of the megadiverse countries
in the world.
Natural resources are
the basis of our economy.
And education is a tool
to eradicate poverty.
If a country has problems with
the economy or development,
this country can survive.
It will have more
time to solve it.
But if a country has problems
with its natural
resources or environment,
this country will not
have more time to solve it
because this is the basis
for their health,
development, and growth,
their heritage, and
their sovereignty.
With my group,
I decided to found a
non-profit institution in 2006.
Now we are focused on
four different programs.
Let's see each one of them.
The first one is
Methodologies.
To teach in a fun way,
those topics that seem
complex to explain.
Now, thanks to the
children's contribution,
we can approach them in
an easy and transcending way.
In fact, children
are very creative.
Thanks to their ideas,
we have generated books,
stories, hand crafts, and games.
Children show us everyday
the best language to teach.
This was a mournful march
to recognize the extinct
species in Mexico.
The 41 extinct species.
When I say
environmental education,
I don't refer to
natural sciences,
I mean a comprehensive vision
of all the issues around.
Here you can see how we approach
water culture,
biodiversity, energy,
environment and ecology,
humanitarian culture,
and also laws.
In fact, we have
an educational plan,
we call it Mondambientes .
Mondambientes in
Spanish stands for,
Changing Environment.
It's like a career to
be an environmentalist
from childhood.
During two years,
a child needs to learn
about these 17 main topics.
But the information
is according to their age.
Let's see only one,
the number 14.
To organize fishing and
sustainable development,
a child is going to learn
about close seasons,
fishing techniques,
ecosystems for fishing,
conservation,
native biodiversity,
and sustainable aquaculture,
and then they can take action.
Because now they have
a comprehensive idea
about how their actions
have a positive impact
on their communities.
The second program is about
courses with workshops
where children are
teaching other children.
Yes, they are training their
peers during two years,
in order to train them as
environmental instructors.
That's why I say that
they are the heroes
of our Grandmother Earth.
Because children's
hands may be small,
but their hearts are
immense to save our planet.
In fact, children who have
participated in this program
have learned about
how to respect nature,
how to respect environment,
but also this program
has changed lifestyle.
Due to the mentorship
activities,
there are children who've
started their own activities,
their own movements,
and they have been awarded
by the Mexican authorities.
In fact, we have met with the
last four presidents of Mexico.
The third program is
sustainable aquaculture
production systems
where we are rescuing
native species
like the Mayan Apple Snail
to the extent that
our communities
are now more aware of
their natural resources.
They will be able
to properly use
their native species,
and also to reactivate
their local economies.
And finally, the fourth
program is Ceiba Pentandra.
Ceiba Pentandra is the name
of the first high-level
environmental educational
training center
in the world.
In 2007 the city of Merida
donated us a land.
In 2012 we started
the construction.
Thanks to the Mexico
Initiative Award
and the Young Laureates
Rolex Award for Enterprise,
there were $500,000 to invest.
It allowed us to build only 30
percent of the construction,
but this year we
have a big challenge.
We need to raise enough funds
to complete the construction.
Only two million dollars.
( audience laughs )
Yeah. And these are some
areas that we need to build.
We need some museums,
we need an aquarium,
a library, and an
experimental laboratory too.
But why is Ceiba
Pentandra so important?
Why? There are other
Mexican states asking
for their own
environmental theme park.
Because with a 100 percent
of the construction
we will be able to receive
64,000 children a year.
With a successful methodology
we can be an ally
for the educational system.
Also, a lot of space
for young people,
handicapped, and elderly.
With our expertise,
we can train teachers,
and provide them methodologies
and materials too.
And also, with our expertise,
we can contribute to
generate the free textbooks
for the educational
system, like this one
for the curriculum.
This project can be
replicated in any place
of Mexico or in the world.
Now, I brought a new project,
and you're going to
be the first ones
to know about this.
In Ceiba Pentandra we
reinvented the Noah's Ark.
Yes, the Noah's Ark.
( audience laughs )
We reinvented...
In moments of crisis,
the Noah's Ark saved,
protected, and rescued
wildlife, all the living beings.
But now our Grandmother Earth
needs our support.
Needs to protect
the living beings now.
Here are some features
of the reinvented Ark
developed in Ceiba Pentandra.
The first one is that
this can cross
geographical borders.
Another novel feature is that
it can adapt
to the urgent needs
of harmonizing
the humans coexistence.
Also the size was redesigned
so that all the tools required
for sustainable management
can be transported,
constructed, or
modified within the ark.
This ark can improve
under adverse situations.
Some contributions
of this new ark
is that if we can activate it
and distribute this prototype
around the world,
we will allow a stronger
human contributions.
Also, we will ensure
the protection
of living beings on
ground and oceans.
We can harmonize the
coexistence of cultures.
And we can save
natural resources.
But thanks to children's
ideas in my organization,
we discovered that with
this reinvented ark,
we can save the most important
species in the world,
humans.
Also, we need your
contributions.
I don't mean money,
although it is also necessary.
( audience laughs )
I mean your ideas, perseverance,
and participation
to consolidate it.
Well, I think that it's time to
discover this reinvented ark.
Are you ready?
( audience )
Yeah!
OK.
This is the reinvented ark.
( audience laughter )
Yes, all this time I was
talking about human brains.
Our brains are like arks.
Each time that we
make a decision
to protect a living being,
a plant, a human, an animal,
we are acting like an ark.
And this ark has
always have been there.
We only need to consolidate it
and to reactivate it.
We only need to
distribute these arks
around the world,
as much as we can.
That's why we need to
consolidate Ceiba Pentandra.
That's why we need more
environmental educational
training centers
around the world.
That's why we need
to train more heroes
of Grandmother Earth.
But we need to work together.
Decision makers, media,
companies, authorities,
we do need you.
See, if we work united,
with these new arks,
we will ensure a prosperous
and harmonious life
for our Grandmother Earth.
Thank you.
( audience applause )
( outro music )